تحركات ومحادثات فلسطينيه اسرائيليه سريه
يجريها كبار مساعدي رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
والرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس في محاوله
لتهدئه التوتر المتصاعد في الضفه الغربيه
بحسب تقرير نشره موقع اكسيوس فان هذه
المحادثات السريه انطلقت منذ شهرين وتعد
من بين اولى الادله على المشاركه المباشره
رفيعه المستوى بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
والحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه الجديده
التي
ركزت على الجهود المبذوله لتهدئه الوضع في
الضفه الغربيه حيث يتصاعد التوتر منذ عده
اشهر وايضا العمل على تسويه التفاهمات
التي ادت الى تعليق التصويت في مجلس الامن
الدولي ضد المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في
الضفه الغربيه والحفاظ ايضا على خط
الاتصال بين القاده من اجل حل المشاكل على
ارض الواقع وفق موقع اكسيوس الذي اشار الى
انه من غير الواضح اذا كان جميع قاده
الاحزاب في ائتلاف نتنياهو وبعضهم من اقصى
اليمين على علم بالمحادثات ومحتواها
الرئيسي ونقلا عن مستشار الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي كشف موقع اكسيوس بان
الفلسطينيين طالبوا اسرائيل بوقف التوغل
في المدن الفلسطينيه وبان اسرائيل اوضحت
انها لا تريد ارسال الجيش الى مدينتي جنين
ونابلس بالضفه الغربيه